By now,
we have seen this picture several times,
where there's one quantity
that we're trying to maximize.
And we have another quantity that
serves as an upper bound for
it, that we're trying to minimize.
And luckily, the two meet at some
point that is optimal for both.
We've just seen this with our primal and
dual linear programs.
But we saw earlier in the semester, as
well, with our max-flow min-cut problem,
and also with our max-matching
in bipartite graphs and
our min vertex cover
in bipartite graphs.
It's natural to ask,
are all these phenomena related?
Well yes they are.
And probably the easiest way to
see that, is to realize that
all of these can be characterized
as liner programs and their duals.
Let’s take a look at duality in
the context of maximum matching and
by bipartite graphs first.
We’ll let the variable xij indicate
whether the edges (i,j) should
be included in the matching.
As a linear program,
the problem becomes to maximize
the number of matches edges, subject to
the constraints that no vertex in
R can be matched more than once.
And no vertex in L can be
matched more than once.
And of course we can't have
negatively matched edges.
To build the dual program,
we'll let yi and
yj be the variables corresponding
to these constraints.
And we'll want to minimize their
sum because the coefficients on
the constraints here are all 1.
For the constraints,
observe that the coefficients
in the objective function are 1.
And that any Xij appears
once in the equation for
i and once in the equation for j.
Hence, yi plus yj is at least 1.
And of course, yi and
yj can't be negative.
The interpretation here
is straightforward.
Vertex i is in the cover,
if and only if yi is 1.
And similarly, vertex j is in
the cover if and only if yj is 1.
Every edge must have at
least one vertex in a cover.
And we're trying to minimize
the size of the cover.
So, we've just seen how
maximum bipartite matching
can be expressed as a linear program,
and it's dual also turned out
to have a natural interpretation
as a vertex cover problem.
This is really neat.
Every decision problem in p can be
converted into a linear program
ultimately, just because linear
programming is P-complete.
But not every conversion
will result in variables and
a dual program that have such
intuitive interpretations.
When this happens, it often gives a way
to gain deeper insight into the problem
and its structure.
As you might have guessed, this happens
also for the max-flow min-cut problem,
and we'll explore that next.